we have a new bombshell report in
Newsweek which claims that Republicans
are more and more agitated by Donald
Trump's problems and by the progress of
the Russia investigation which daily is
tightening around Trump and his family
rather than loosening to the point that
Los Angeles Times reporter Eli's Stowe
khals said on MSNBC yesterday that
Republicans are privately telling him
that if Muller has more wrongdoing by
Trump than just these felonies he
directed Michael Cohen to commit that if
they obtain information that suggests
Trump approved of wrongdoing or even had
knowledge of wrongdoing that they may
dump Trump to save the Republican Party
check out what Eli Stokoe said yesterday
to Nicole Wallace on MSNBC but when all
the facts are laid out and people can
see the investigators work I think it's
going to be very problematic for this
president and there is some
understanding I think inside the White
House of just how dark it may be getting
especially in terms of conversations
private conversations that people they
are having with Republicans on the hill
who are starting to be concerned
Republican lawmakers who are have a huge
role to play in this if it goes forward
are starting to tell me privately some
of them that you know if there's obvious
evidence the bottoms gonna fall out
they're not going to be able to stand by
this White House and that's a looming
problem for the president so this is a
reporter claiming it
there are right-wingers writing this off
as merely made-up but this is not a
pundit right Eli Stoker's is a reporter
for the Los Angeles Times he has serious
sources in Washington DC he has no
reason to make this up the risks to him
professionally to just making this up
are huge and more importantly he's not
really saying anything that's hard to
believe
privately on the condition of anonymity
Republicans are telling him we're aware
of how bad this is we are aware that if
it gets bad and it gets worse simply
standing by Trump no matter what comes
out would be bad for us obviously right
who could fault them for that they care
about self-preservation they don't
really
care about Trump Trump's not even been a
Republican most of his life and he has
no particular loyalty to the Republican
Party beyond it being the team that he
chose to play on right now as President
Trump we would be expecting Republicans
to be saying this we stand behind Trump
up until the point at which it becomes
damaging for us and for the party and
then we're going to bail and
interestingly stoical said during the
same amount of MSNBC appearance that the
Giuliani Trump plan right now is to keep
attacking the investigators we've said
this before Pat and will say it again I
don't remember who it was that tweeted
Sarah Huckabee Sanders maybe when you're
attacking FBI investigators you know
that you're in trouble if your strongest
tactic is to attack the people doing the
investigation you're not in a strong
position it sounds to me like attacking
investigators is a sign of weakness a
sign that they don't have anything and a
poor argument really what we're seeing
is the development of Trump from a sort
of political curiosity into a political
liability which was predicted pretty
early on in Trump's campaign that this
is what it would become
and there may even be some way in which
Republicans as they see the stock market
become more and more erratic as they see
the jobs numbers fall further and
further behind expectations as they see
the world laughing at us day in and day
out there are some Republicans who don't
really care about Trump who might be
hoping that whatever Moeller comes up
with is really serious and unequivocal
and definitive so that they can say
listen I'm a Republican and I like the
president but if he did something of
that bad then he just has to go
Republicans may be hoping that Robert
Moeller provides them cover to dump
Trump now what would it mean to dump
Trump because that could take many forms
one would be related to what we talked
about earlier if the house does move to
impeach Donald Trump in the new Congress
Republicans in the Senate could just get
on board right they could vote to remove
him although for some of them for many
of them maybe there would be political
consequences to doing that there are
slightly more subtle methods that
Republicans could employ for example
they could communicate the Donald Trump
that Republicans will not be supporting
him in his re-election campaign instead
they're going to be supporting a
challenger maybe Trump should consider
not running and allowing someone else to
run these are all extreme scenarios but
we're increasingly sort of operating in
a universe of extreme scenarios they
could negotiate if you drop out of
running for re-election
we won't impeach you or look to
prosecute you after you're out of office
many scenarios but the fact that any of
this is even being talked about means
we're already starting to approach what
could potentially be the endgame phase
of this national nightmare or maybe
Trump just gets reelected and serves
eight full years and then leaves office
and never faces any consequences that's
also a possibility what do you think I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we'll
be back after this today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blinka it's amazing it's an app for your
phone tablet or web browser and what
they do is they take nonfiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good also bunk by
Kevin Young useful in preparing me for
the pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
is comm slash Pakman if you're watching
on youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n